the u.s government says it is drawing up
yet another round of anti-russia
sanctions
the announcement was made on the same
day the russian ambassador returned to
the united states almost three months
after being recalled to moscow amid a
rising tensions it's come as a surprise
to many given the largely upbeat
messages that last week's putin biden
summit in geneva
russia's foreign ministry spokesperson
said moscow will retaliate
we have always given a consistent
response to illegal actions of the
united states
it is strange that some people in
washington enjoy this obstacle course so
much
american ideologues have revealed
themselves they need all of the fuss
around the supposed poisoning
as a tool for solving the problems of
their own non-competitiveness
the new sanctions are said to be related
to the case of russian opposition figure
alexa navalny and
also target russian companies engaged in
the nordstrom 2 project
upon his arrival in the u.s the russian
ambassador noted that
despite the recent summit not much seems
to have changed when it comes to
american policy
that's not the result everyone was
expecting after the summit
i don't believe that sanctions can
stabilize relations between countries
dialogue must be restored first of all
back in geneva
unlike many of my colleagues i spoke
very carefully about the outcome of the
summit
saying that i believe in actions not
words i said that we should wait and see
what our american colleagues do
it's sad that they have chosen a path
that does not lead us to the positive
outcome that both presidents sought
we have very serious issues but we are
ready to talk constructively to solve
them
meanwhile the white house said it will
take up to one year for washington to
decide whether it's possible to have a
strategic dialogue with moscow and also
it's hard to imagine russia as the
friend in the future
independent journalist martin summers
says that the upcoming sanctions reveal
the clout of the anti-russia
lobby in america well i think it shows
disarray
on the u.s side it was always going to
be very difficult
for biden to make any kind of
concessions
because uh there's a huge lobby
inside the united states based within
the the sort of security apparatus
and the media who are determined to
sabotage constructive relations between
russia and the west
the faction which are pushing for the
sanctions
they weren't very happy perhaps that the
meeting took place at all
and therefore they've now you know
carried out their machinations
in order to prevent anything positive
coming out of it and
at the same time there's a sort of
schizophrenia uh it makes
it's just common sense that the two
sides should talk to each other
so of course we've had the meeting last
week but i can't say
i'm terribly surprised to see that the
the reiteration of the hostility
which has now become endemic
you